[Applause]
along the u.s canadian border the
trucker's blockade is slowly taking its
toll this paddle boarder is moving
faster than traffic
and as rebels and 18 wheelers demanding
an end to covet 19 restrictions continue
using their freedom convoy to block the
border on the canadian side the pain is
being felt on both sides
ford has stopped its auto assembly line
in windsor toyota has closed three
plants across ontario and general motors
is cutting shifts in michigan and those
closures threaten to reverberate
throughout the auto supply chain
despite the added time in traffic this
trucker says the demonstrators have a
point everybody
has the right you know to do whatever
you want you know
i want to die i want to die i don't care
i support them you know but i think it
kind of sucks you know all the traffic
here you know
on thursday the truckers opened another
front blocking all lanes on manitoba's
main crossing to north dakota and with
the ambassador bridge blocked from
detroit to windsor traffic on the
busiest land crossing in north america
is shut down entirely from the u.s to
canada and all but closed in the other
direction
trucks carrying everything from cattle
to car parts which under automaker's
just-in-time delivery system need to be
delivered within 48 hours to keep
assembly lines rolling have been
diverted to the crossing between port
huron michigan and the canadian city of
sarnia at the bluewater bridge these
trucks are getting across to canada but
wait times have been up to three hours
and traffic crawls and that's likely to
continue as long as the trucker's
blockade goes on and politicians seem
unwilling to crack down
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
insists canada will follow the science
not only are canadians tired of this
pandemic of
of the challenges we're facing but
they're also of course tired of the
restrictions tired of the rules tired of
the lockdowns that is understandable but
you know what helps lift restrictions
you know what helps move beyond
lockdowns
vaccinations
but some canadian provinces including
alberta and saskatchewan have eased
coveted rules and quebec and prince
edward island announced plans to do the
same
but with plans for a freedom convoy in
the u.s the truckers protests show no
sign of ending
john hendren al jazeera on the u.s
border with canada